Hãy hợp của các bạn, các bạn thấy sẽ là người đồng thành của người đoạn.
Sôi đến hết các bạn, các bạn thấy nhường, nhá ngại lần nữa, việc hợp của bạn hơn vẫn phải đồng hạ tân quyền.
Đúng không? Điểm số thống bạn vẫn phải cho chính các bạn quyền.
Hãy sẽ là người đường dẫn và bị giúp cho các bạn nạn để mức trường.
Nhà, có việc cho bạn hợp, các bạn phải đồng hạc.
Bây giờ có lịch hợp dối các không vào hợp, để chúng ta cũng chịu.
Tại không thể kiện cho mỗi mẹ các bạn đến, giúp các bạn hợp.
Vậy các bạn có mẹ luôn, các bạn có mẹ luôn.
Vậy hẹn gửi đúng.
Thái chỉ là quá một phần, và phân là phải là khóa.
Chính nhất, vảy bạc là khóa sẽ, mình thấy quyền tâm,
để thằng này lắm của chúng ta sẽ có nhiều đường chỉ đi một lời.
Hãy cho các bạn kiểu kiểu kiểu nhá.